[Musique]
en france aussi les delphinariums sont
contestés peut-on encore aujourd'hui
mettre la mère en prison
à saint jean cap ferrat à quelques
kilomètres à peine du marineland côte
d'azur sos grand bleu collecte des
pétitions du monde entier pour lutter
contre le principe des show aquatique en
nous voulons surtout que le public c'est
un petit peu conscients des drames qui
vivait au fil des ans la reine du monde
puisqu'il ya en aussi bien des
informations total de la vie de la vie
réelle des dauphins dans ce genre
d'établissement
donc nous voulons simplement que les
publics quand il va le payer un billet
d'entrée dans ce défi nario connaissent
la vérité on les 24 premiers mois de
captivité on a à peu près 30% de dauphin
qui meurent 50% pour les tursiops et
après bon c'est une longue agonie
dauphin ne vit pas plus de sept ans en
moyenne en captivité en liberté une vie
peut vivre jusqu'à 40 ans il ya un gros
mensonge souvent travers les marineland
on nous fait croire que animaux sont
heureux qu'ils sont bien il un dauphin
ça sourit tout le temps même si vous
couper en tranches insee d'anatomie
sourit tout le temps on fait croire que
la demo il ya un espèce de symbiose de
courant qui passe entre le dresseur de
dauphins
c'est pas vrai le dauphin il obéit il
faut qu'ils mangent tous qu'il a soignée
[Musique]
oh